Donald Trump's approval rating is down
again let's take a look at the Trump
approval rating chart you'll remember
that a couple of weeks ago Trump
approval bottomed out at 37% or rent a
record low for a president 60 days in
earlier this week I told you about the
new bottom of 36 percent and now as you
can see there another new bottom of 35
percent this is this is a chart of the
Gallup daily tracking poll it's a three
day rolling average it's an
apples-to-apples comparison
Gallup has been doing this for decades
59 percent now disapprove of the job
that Donald Trump is doing my reaction
remains Pat how is it so high how is
Donald Trump's approval rating 35
percent who were the one-third of
Americans who see what he's doing and
say I approve it baffles us but at least
it's no surprise that that number is
going down because usually there's a
honeymoon phase after a new president
gets inaugurated and we see that in his
case that honeymoon phase is very
short-lived yet lasted like three days
and of course he came in with record low
approval as well how do you react to
this if your Trump you say that the
polls are fake I mean I genuinely don't
know how you distance yourself from the
numbers or try to deal ajith amaizing
them at this point I guess you just
think that you have time because you
have three whole years before the next
election process starts up you try to
change course a little bit but we know
that he's not really willing to change
his mind at this time I don't know like
what a tax reform bill bump up his
approval rating not if it doesn't help
most people I I genuinely don't know at
this point what needs to happen which is
why I keep getting back to you if
there's a terror incident and Trump
seems to coalesce the nation that's what
is his biggest opportunity is to raise
his approval rating he could reach out
to Democrats a little bit more in a the
only way he could do that now is the
infrastructure bill that he's talking
about maybe although in his budget he
after cheerleading that he was gonna
spend money on infrastructure he cut it
so yet another broken campaign promise
I've been saying for a while that
sustained low 30s would start to be
trouble and I guess we're like what
wouldn't you consider low 30s like 33 I
would consider low 30s already I think
that's because you are 33 and want to
say that you're in your
early 30s but I would say low 30s is 30
31 and 32
okay well 33 is definitely low 30s yeah
so I think that Trump is basically two
points away from what I would start to
consider trouble and the question to
Republicans will soon be if Trump's
approval doesn't start climbing is Trump
so great that you're willing to risk
losing your seat over supporting Donald
Trump publicly and an important note
here is you don't get down to 35 unless
at least some Republicans are not
approving however not approving is not
the same as saying you would vote for a
Democrat and this is where I think
sometimes Democrats get overwhelmed they
say 35 percent approval Trump can't win
there are Republicans who do not approve
of the job Trump is doing but would not
vote for Hillary Clinton if the election
were held today would not vote for
Bernie Sanders if the election were
heard today held today so it's important
not to translate disapproval into I
would definitely vote for an alternative
well let's remember that Donald Trump
lost the popular vote by two percentage
points so he would have to win over a
lot of people to make up that ground of
it and we have to remember also that an
approval poll is not a poll of likely
voters so we're talking about two
different things here send me your
thoughts about this how low will it go
it's presidential approval linga limbo
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show